مشهد التوتر المحتدم بين كوسوفو وصربيا
يتصاعد يوما بعد يوم لتصبح زاويه تبادل
الاتهامات بين رؤساء البلدين سيده الموقف
وتغطي على معارك الميدان التي لم تسفر عن
اصابات اليوم
فعلى ما يبدو صربيا لا تزال
عثماني التي اتهمت نظيرها الصربي بتقديم
الدعم لجماعات مسلحه واشعال فتيل الفتنه
شمالي البلاد
السبب هو دعم رئيس الصربيا الكسندر
فوتشيتش سياسيا وماليا هياكل غير قانونيه
تحولت الى عصابات اجراميه هي جماعات
الجريمه المنظمه العابره للحدود وهي
مجموعات خطيره للغايه تسببت ايضا في العنف
ضد جنود النيتو
الرئيس الصربي الكسندر رمى كره الجليد في
ملعب نظيرته لاخماد الاشتباك الدائر عبر
التراجع عن القرار المتعلق برؤساء
البلديات الالبان ليرد على اتهاماتها
باستعداده اقناع شعبه بالاحتجاج بهدوء في
وقت دفع بتعزيزات عسكريه لجيشه على الحدود
انهم مصممون وحاسمون للغايه اعتقد ان
الخطوه التي قد تحل المشاكل هي انسحاب
رؤساء البلديات المزعومين
تخوفات اوروبيه من مشهد التصعيد بين
البلدين وصدعوات الى نزعفه للتوتر على
الفور ودون قيد او شرط فالخلاف القائم
قديم جديد عمره عقدان من الزمن لكنه قد
ينذر بتفجير محتمل في اوروبا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات